see why it's the paperwork to separate
you you it's really incredible I could
actually see the end of your friendship
George do something let the pin down mr.
Krupp or will hypnotize you when I snap
my fingers you will obey our every
command come sidekick we gotta stop em
why thank you
vehicle person yeah which robber you'll
get him what is happening right now
I don't know I just try and leave if you
what happens Wow that's an expensive
door mm-hmm
the studio that brought you Shrek Kung
Fu Panda and Madagascar hi I'm George
beard miss my best friend Harold
Hutchins we just make comics and try to
make each other laugh and this old guy
is mr. crup daughter
he's the world's principal in the world
ever since you attended two schools
you've been responsible for one franc
after another some of those must have
been really hard to pull off like that
tiger or that tackle is crazy
ah I told you I'd get you one day I'm
going to have you to place it's that
good as it we're going to annihilate the
friendship
do something put the pin down mr. truck
or wheel hypnotize you my fingers you
will obey our every command I'll see
that they don't happen this summer comes
Arctic we got a stop haha thank you
vehicle person oh yeah which probably
will get them their greatest creation
Captain Underpants you can't actually
fly I take to the sky like an awesome
wow he is super dumb give it even hell
biggest problem that's how you pay from
a worldwide phenomenon are you Claire
I'm your new teacher not some scary guy
with a secret evil agenda guys I totally
got yeah totally he's got it
Kevin Hart Ed Helms Thomas Middleditch
it's cool
when it's cut all together like that you
really get a sense of the scope
DreamWorks Captain Underpants more so
you're trapped in some sort of invisible
box like prison is it okay that I'm kind
of loving this yes enough I will set you
free
Oh mostly yes
you